avec vous Hélène frad bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline à la une de la presse
les réactions on en parlait à l'instant
en français en Europe à la victoire de
la coalition des droites emmenés par là
poste fasciste Georgia Meloni ou
législatives en Italie il y a des
guillemets autour du terme car il fait
débat Hélène dans la presse française
s'est ajoutée au malheur du monde disait
l'écrivain français Albert Camus mais
comment précisément nommer les Fratelli
d'Italia désormais premier parti
politique d'Italie la croix qui récule
cette appellation poste fasciste parce
que selon le journal Les Fratelli
d'Italia n'aurait toujours pas seul de
leur compte avec le passé fasciste
évoque un parti d'extrême droite
conservateur et souverainiste dont
l'arrivée au pouvoir constitue un
tournant pour l'Europe et un défi pour
la France comme pour l'Europe un défi et
un tournant estime également le Figaro
qui parle lui d'un parti souverain et
post fasciste une étiquette collée au
front comme une marque d'infamie je cite
qui risque de valoir à Georgia Meloni
d'être renvoyé aux origines sulfureuses
et au symbole encombrantes sont partis
au moindre dérapages pour Libération la
messe et dite pour le journal la large
victoire de Joe jameloni est une
nouvelle manifestation de la poussée du
fascisme en Europe une victoire qui
vient gonfler le poids des dirigeants
ultra conservateur et d'extrême droite
remettant en cause les valeurs de l'UE
d'où ce titre toutes les peurs mènent à
Rome libération qui publie ce dessin
signé coco chercher l'erreur la
dessinatrice aux lois fait référence aux
manifester manifestations actuellement
en Iran où les femmes se coupent les
cheveux et brûlent leur voile pour
protester contre le régime une flamme
dont Joe jameloni elle s'est emparée
elle qui prêche
du droit la restriction pardon du droit
à l'IVG et la défense de la famille dite
naturel elle en a fait on le voit le
symbole des flatelles il Italia c'est un
symbole sulfureux on le rappelle
puisqu'il a été utilisé en Italie par le
mouvement social italien fondé par des
nostalgiques de Mussolini et en France
parce par le Front national nouvellement
rassemblement national alors Hélène que
les marchés financiers avaient les yeux
rivés sur un cette possibilité de voir
l'extrême droite triomphé en Italie et
bien c'est finalement au Royaume-Uni que
la panique c'est finalement déclenché
hier mais la livre sterling à
l'intérieur un niveau plus bas
historique face au dollar la crise de la
livre s'aggrave à mesure que la
stratégie de l'estress se défait annonce
de gardiennes courbe catastrophique à
l'appui la dégringolade de la livre à la
Une également de l'hebdo de New Rapion
particulièrement remonté contre
voici cartés il est le nouveau ministre
des Finances britanniques l'hebdo
étrille je cite ses erreurs d'écoliers
erreur commises selon l'hebdo dans les
mesures que le chancelier de l'Échiquier
a présenté la semaine dernière à midi
budget au Maxi Best d'impôts accusé
d'aggraver la débâcle économique au
Royaume-Uni voici carthagne qu'on
retrouve dans le dessin de Moten Morland
pour The Times en compagnie de la
première ministre listress à la barre du
Royaume-Uni au plus tôt d'un bateau
ivre qui semble sur le point de faire
naufrage le duo trust cartonne qu'on
retrouve en chute libre cette fois dans
le dessin de Martin Rosen pour le
gardien dans une salle de classe
kirstamer le patron des travails
démontre que leur soi-disant théorie
économie du ruissellement provoque en
réalité une dégringolade économique
elle a une également aujourd'hui le
durcissement de la répression contre le
déserteur en Russie Hélène ou le code
pénal prévoit désormais jusqu'à 10 ans
de prison en cas de refus d'aller
combattre en Ukraine notre cette mesure
le président Poutine a décidé
d'interdire les hommes en âge d'être
mobilisés de quitter la Russie d'après
ABC le journal espagnol Pauline cite le
chiffre de plus de 260 000 hommes ayant
déjà fui le pays en moins d'une semaine
c'est-à-dire depuis l'entrée en vigueur
du décret de mobilisation dite partielle
parmi ces déserteurs il y a Vitali 29
ans rencontrer par le quotidien français
Le Parisien Aujourd'hui en France à BBC
en Géorgie jusque là vendeur de
téléphone dans une boutique high tech ce
jeune homme raconte qu'il venait tout
juste de déménager dans l'appartement
qu'il avait acheté avec sa petite amie
quand le discours de Vladimir Poutine la
brutalement jeté dans l'exil sans même
attendre l'ordre de mobilisation vitale
dit être partie pour ne pas risquer je
le cite de rentrer chez lui dans un sac
en plastique le témoignage de Vitaly
dans Le Parisien et puis rapidement pour
terminer et laine quelques mots de la
démission hier de Julien Bayou le numéro
1 d'Europe Écologie Les Verts en tout
cas jusqu'ici accusé de violences
psychologiques le site envers son
ex-compagne qui fait beaucoup de bruit
ici en France depuis plusieurs jours
intervient peu de temps après la mise en
cause du député de la française soumise
Adrien katnas pour des fêtes de
violences conjugales cette affaire est
en train de tourner elle aussi aux
règlements de compte politique
libération rapporte que l'avocate de
Julien Bayou a indirectement accusé des
membres d'Europe Écologie Les Verts de
chercher à mener je la cite une croisade
alors que le Congrès des écologistes
approche à grands pas parmi eux l'élu
Sandrine Rousseau qui a médiatisé cette
affaire et qui s'attire ce commentaire
ma foi plutôt cinglant de libération
Rousseau nourries les polémiques et sans
nourris cela fait parfois du mal à la
gauche mais qui fait du bien la scène
notoriété merci beaucoup Hélène c'était
l'arbuste presse à retrouver bien sûr en
podcast